this like most elections before it is
likely to be a straight two-horse race
between a conservative yoon tsukyo and
his liberal opponent li jie myeong with
both of them fighting against their own
unpopularity a fact they seem to accept
two-party politics with vested interest
offer limited choices as a result people
are left to buy the bullet and choose
the less of the two evils
neither has international standing but
they are vying for a job that now has
global reach there's south korea's
importance in the world economy
especially in high-tech manufacturing
its cultural clout is growing through
movies drama and k-pop and its key
geo-political role in sino-us relations
as well as its fraught dealings with
north korea the outgoing liberal
president moon jae-in has made it his
mission to improve inter-korean ties
but his term is ending with the north
increasing its missile testing with the
threat of launching longer-range
ballistic missiles that have brought the
peninsula to the brink of conflict in
the past
there is a high possibility that various
missile tests will be conducted
intensively after the presidential
election on march 9th
and if he wins yunsukyo has promised a
tougher line with the north including
the possibility of pre-emptive strikes
against its newly developed hypersonic
missiles
if it's carrying a nuclear weapon the
time it will take to reach the capital
area and commit a massacre is under a
minute it's practically impossible to
intercept
whether or not this election will result
in worsening into korean relations
what's almost guaranteed is its fair
share of controversy both candidates
come into this race marred by domestic
scandal and that's before the campaign
mudslinging really gets underway
this is a country where the job of
president has often ended in the
disgrace of coups resignations or
imprisonment as this campaign starts
park jung haye returns to life as an
ordinary citizen following her pardon
and release from a 22-year sentence one
of four former presidents to have spent
time behind bars
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul